[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن اسقاط 10 مسيرات
اوكرانيه حاولت استهداف مواقع في شبه
جزيره القرم
الملك سلمان يصدر امرا بتحديد اليوم
الحادي عشر من شهر مارس من كل عام يوما
للعلم
صحيفه كويتيه تكشف عن صدور مرسوم من عشره
ضوابط لتنظيم التركيبه السكانيه في البلاد
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
مجلس الوزراء السعودي يوافق على تحويل
شريك من برنامج الى مركز لتعزيز الشراكه
مع القطاع الخاص
انطلاقه معرض للعماره والتصميم في الخبر
شرق السعوديه بمشاركه مختصين وطلبه جامعات
حياكم الله افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انه تم احباط محاوله من قبل نظام كيف لشنه
هجوم كبير بطائرات دون طيار على اهداف في
شبه جزيره القرم وبحسب الوزاره اسقطت
انظمه الدفاع الجوي 6 طائرات من دون طيار
كما عطلت اربع طائرات عن طريق التشويش
الالكتروني
اعرب وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه مترو كلبا
عن فقره ببلاده وشركائه الذين وقفوا الى
جانبها لتتجاوز اوكرانيا اصعب شتاء في
تاريخهم شهدت خلاله قصفا روسيا مكثفا اغرق
ملايين المدنيين بالظلام واكد كلبا انه هو
بالرغم من قسوه الشتاء والهجوم الروسي
الذي استهدف الكثير من مواقع الطاقه وقطع
الطياره وقطع التيارات الكهربائيه الا ان
اوكرانيا لم ترضخ وانما تصدت للهجمات بكل
ما اوتيت به من قوه على حد وصفه مشيرا الى
ان الطريق نحو النصر النهائي ما زال طويلا
لكنه سيكون حليفا لاوكرانيا
لا تزال جبهات القتال ساخنه في شرق
اوكرانيا تحديدا في محيط باقي التي اقر
الجيش الاوكراني ان الوضع فيها باته صعبا
جدا وافاد مراسل العربيه بان قوه فاغنر
سيطرت على عده احياء جنوب باخموت فيما كتف
الجيش الروسي الهجمات لمحاصره المدينه
وتمكن من قطع ثلاثه طرق اوكرانيه لعبور
الامدادات في موازاه ذلك اعلن الجيش
الروسي تعرض خمس مناطق في روسيا لهجوم
بمسيره استهدفت البنت التحتيه المدنيه
اللافت ان احدى المسيرات وصلت قرب العاصمه
موسكو للمره الاولى منذ بدء الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه
ومعنا من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم
كاتيا مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض اذا حدثت الواخر وربما اخر
الاعلانات من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بانها
احبطت هجوما كبيرا كان سيستهدف جزيره
القرد ماذا لديك من معلومات كم من مدينه
كانت تحاول هذه الطائرات ان تستهدفها واذا
كان من معلومات ايضا عن التوقيت
مرحبا نايف بالفعل هجوم واسع النطاق كانت
قد شهدته الاراضي الروسيه خلال يوم امس
اليوم الدفاع الروسيه اضافت الى البيانات
التي شهدناها يوم امس ايضا من محاوله
استهداف خمس مدن روسيه من بينها الضواحي
موسكو ضواحي العاصمه موسكو كان هناك هجوم
موسعه استهدف شبه جزيره القرم من قبل
طائرات مسيره اوكرانيا كما قالت الدفاع
الروسيه كانت قد اسقطت ست طائرات مسيره
بالاضافه لتعطيلها اربع طائرات اخرى وايضا
قامت باسقاط 15 طائره مسيره في المناطق
الانفصاليه في دونيسكو في خرسون ايضا هذا
ياتي طبعا ضمن هذه الحمله التي شهدتها
روسيا خلال يوم امس واليوم من استهدافات
للاراضي الروسيه كان الكريم لانه ايضا علق
على تعليق طبعا او نفي الجانب الاوكراني
باستهداف الاراضي الروسيه بطائرات مسيره
بانها بان موسكو لا تصدق طبعا
تصريحات كيف بانها لا تقوم باستهداف
الاراضي الروسيه طبعا الطائرات المسيره
التي استهدفت العاصمه او ضواحي العاصمه
موسكو هي طبعا لم تؤدي الى سقوط ضحايا هي
كانت من طراز ستريش وهي مسيارات تعود الى
فتره حقبه الاتحاد السوفياتي تستطيع قطع
مسافات تصل الى الاف الكيلومترات وتستطيع
حمل ايضا الذخيره على متنها نايف كذلك
ايضا كان هنالك انباء عن سقوط احدى
الطائرات المسيره او استهداف احدى
الطائرات المسيره ربما في هذا الهجوم او
ايضا في هجوم اخر وانها وصلت هذه الطائره
مسيره بالقرب من العاصمه موسكو هل تحدثت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن هذا الامر هل حدث
فعلا
حقيقه يوم امس خرج
عمده موسكو تحدث عن ان هناك مسيره تم
اسقاطها كانت تستهدف احد القطاعات التابعه
لشركه وهو عباره عن محطه غاز غاز طبعا لم
تصل الى الهدف تم اسقاطها قبل الوصول لم
تسبب بوقوع ضحايا او
تسبب لم تؤدي الى انفجار طبعا ولكن كما
تحدث خبراء عسكريون طبعا هو هذا الاستهداف
الاول الذي يصل او المسيره الاولى التي
تصل الى ضواحي موسكو ولكن كما تحدثها
خبراء عسكريون ان العاصمه الروسيه محصنه
بشكل جيد هي محاطه بانظمه دفاع جويه قادره
على اسقاط اي طائره مسيره قد
تكون موجهه الى العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
طبعا وعلى خلفيه هذه الحوادث بالتاكيد
هناك تحصين جديد او تكثيف بحمايه العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو من اي استهداف خارجي او
اختراق لجسم غريب
بالاراضي الروسيه نايف اشكرك جزيل الشكر
من موسكو مراسله العربيه طعمه على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
قالت الخارجيه الالمانيه انها تراقب بقلق
برامج التسلح الايرانيه المتقدمه لاسباب
عده اقلها ان ايران تصاعد في العديد من
المناطق حاليا فضلا عن تقسيم اليورانيوم
في فوردو والقمع الوحشي للشعب الايراني
وانشطه طهران المزعزع للاستقرار في
المنطقه
وخارجها من خلال مبيعات الطائرات المسيره
لروسيا الخارجيه الالمانيه اشارت الى ان
قرار طهران من دبلوماسيه كان متوقعا لكنه
ليس مبررا
اتهم رئيس هيئه العمليات في الجيش
الاسرائيلي عديد باسيوك ايران بمحاوله
استهداف قطع بحريه بالمسيرات في بحر العرب
الشهر الماضي باسيوك اكد ايضا ان طهران
حاولت الاستهداف لمرتين مشيرا الى ان
الخطط الاسرائيليه ضد ايران مطروحه على
الطاوله وستستخدمها حاله الاضطرار لذلك
في ايران ايضا يستمر مسلسل تسمم الطالبات
تعرض الطالبات مدرستين ثانويه وابتدائيه
للتسمم في العاصمه الايرانيه طهران وتم
ارسال قوات الطوارئ الى المكان وذكر
اولياء امور الطالبات في المدرسه الثانويه
بمنطقه طه انه تم اطلاق نوع من الرذاذ في
المدرسه تسبب في التسمم وفي المدرسه
الابتدائيه للبنات بمنطقه نارمك تم القاء
غاز سام ايضا وتجمع اولياء الامور وهتفوا
ضد النظام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
متابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
المباشره
لمحاوله رفع انقاذ القطار هذا القطار طبعا
الذي كان قد تعرض الى حادث اصطدام مع قطار
اخر في اليونان وادى بحياه 32 شخصا واصابه
طبعا خمسه وثمانين شخصا في
اليونان اذا طبعا كانت الخدمات الطوارئ
اليونانيه قد تحدثت بان هذا القطار كان
يحمل اكثر من 350 شخص اصطدم بقطار شحن اخر
بعد منتصف الليل بفتره وجيزه بتوقيت
المحلي في ذات المنطقه قرب مدينه لاريسا
اذا هذه صور من ننقلها لكم مباشره على
شاشه العربيه
لرفع انقاض هذا او عفوا لرفع يعني هذا
وحطام هذا القطار الذي اصطدم بقطار اخر
واوداب حياه 32 شخصا واصابه
85 اخرين
ما تزال قوته الامن الاسرائيليه تجري
عمليات بحث ومطارده لمنفذ عمليه اطلاق
النار في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس بدايه
الاسبوع الحالي والتي ادت الى مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين كما تحصل القوات
الاسرائيليه مدينه اريحا وتعيق الدخول
والخروج منها بحثا عن خليه اطلقت النار
على مركبه اسرائيليه وقتلت سائقها ونفذ
الجيش الاسرائيلي حمله مداهمات واسعه
تخللها اعتقال عدد من الفلسطينيين وسط
مواجهات شهدتها المدن الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه
ومن رام الله ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الحفيظ جعوان عبد الحفيظ مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
ربما اخر الانباء
المتعلقه بهذا الامر صدرت عن الصحه
الفلسطينيه التي يعني ذكرت بان هناك اصابه
لثلاثه فلسطينيين في الاقتحام الاسرائيلي
لمخيم عقبه جابر باريحا كيف يمكن تقييمها
اخر المعلومات كذلك
في هذا الاقتحام كان يخص الخليه
الفلسطينيه التي نفذت عمليه اطلاق نار قبل
يومين وعدت الى مقتل مستوطن بالقرب من
مدينه اريحا وذلك وفق وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
تقول ان القوه الاسرائيليه التي اقتحمت
مخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا قبل نحو ساعه بشكل
مفاجئ قامت باغتيال احد الفلسطينيين وقامت
باعتقال عدد اخر من الفلسطينيين منهم من
نفذ عمليه اطلاق النار وتدعي وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه انها خليه تابعه خليه
مسلحه تابعه لحركه حماس هي التي نفذت هذه
العمليه وان هذا الهجوم كان يستهدف هذه
الخليه كان هناك محاصره لمنزل او منزلين
داخل مخيم عقبه جبر اطلقت الصواريخ
المحموله على الكتف من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه على المنزل ماده على ما يبدو
لاصابه عدد من الفلسطينيين واعتقال اخرين
وفق المصادر الفلسطينيه حتى الان فقط
اصابه واحده التي الى مستشفى اريح الحكومه
الاصابه الاخرى الخطيره اخذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي معه ولا يعرف ان كان هو احد
يعني الخليه المستهدفه ام شخص اخر يعني
شاب يمر في الطريق ولكن منع التواكم
الاسعاف من تقديم العلاج له واخذه الجنود
معهم الذين انسحبوا قبل دقائق فقط نايف
يعني انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي من مخيم عقبه
جبر ووسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تقول ان
الحساب المفتوح مع هذه الخليه التي نفذت
هذه العمليه قد انتهى وبالتالي سنرى خلال
الساعات القادمه ان كان هناك ردود فعل
الفلسطينيه او ان كانت اسرائيل سوف تزيل
الحواجز التي كانت قد فرضتها على مدينه
اريحا خلال اليومين السابقين وكما تعرف
نايف يعني مدينه اريحة هي مدينه سياحيه
بالدرجه الاولى وهي بوابه الفلسطينيين الى
العالم كل فلسطيني يريد السفر عليها ان
يمر من مدينه اريحا وبالتالي كان هناك
اعاقات كبيره وتاثير بشكل مباشر على حياه
الناس الان العمليه العسكريه انتهت وتقول
اسرائيل انها
قامت باغتيال احد منفذي هذه العمليه
واعتقال اخرين واخذتهم الى مكان لاجراء
ومباشره عمليه الاغتيال هذا هذا حسب
المصادر الاسرائيليه الصحفيه يعني لا
تاكيدات من الصحه الفلسطينيه حول هذه
العمليه عمليه الاغتيال صح الفلسطينيه
تحدثت فقط عن ثلاثه اصابات
نعم عاده في مثل هذه الامور هناك اتصالات
تجري بين الارتباط الفلسطيني والارتباط
الاسرائيلي للتبليغ عن وقوع اصابات او
وقوع قتله وما الى ذلك ويبلغ الارتباط
الفلسطيني ووزاره الصحه بشان الاصابات او
ان كان هناك ضحايا لهذا الهجوم ما وصلنا
من وزاره الصحه ان يعني هناك اتصالات تجري
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي لمعرفه نتائج هذه
العمليه لان الجنود عمليا قصفو المنزل
بصاروخ وحدث هناك اشتباك مسلح ولا نعرف من
اعتقل ومن اصيب ننقل عن وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه بانه احد الشبان يعني احد
افراد هذه الخليه تم اغتياله في داخل
المنزل واعتقل اخرين ولكن ننتظر التاكيدات
الرسميه من وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه التي
عادتا ما تتلقى هذه المعلومات من الجانب
الاسرائيلي الرسمي ماذا عن الوضع حتى هذه
اللحظه في حواء عبد الحفيظ العاده الحيات
الى حواره هل تم فتح المدينه مره اخرى ام
لا زالت مغلقه بسبب الاجراءات والتدابير
العسكريه هناك
يعني الامور تعود شيئا بشيء الى طبيعتها
اليوم جامعه النجاح اعلنت عن عوده الدوام
بشكل طبيعي ايضا بعض المدارس فتحت ابوابها
بعد ايام من الاغلاق نتيجه الاعتداءات
المستوطنين المتواصله ولكن ما زالت الخليه
او الشخص الذي نفذ عمليه اطلاق النار في
حواره وادت الى مقتل
مستوطنين ما زالت القوات الاسرائيليه تجري
عمليات بحث واسعه خلف هذا المنفذ وما زال
هناك يعني انتشار واسع وكثيف للجنود
الاسرائيليين سواء داخل بلده حواره او في
محيط هذه البلده ومحيط مدينه نابلس ما زال
الاهالي نايف في مدينه حواره لا ينامون
الليل ويسهرون طوال الليل خشيه من هجمات
انتقاميه اخرى للمستوطنين وبالتالي الامور
لم تعد الى طبيعتها ما دام هناك استنفار
اسرائيلي كبير ما دام هناك مستوطنون
يواصلون التهديد بالتنفيذ عمليات انتقاميه
ضد اهداف فلسطينيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
رام الله مراسل العربيه عبد الحفيظ جاون
بعد مره اخرى الى الملف الذي بدانا به
نشره الرابعه الملف ملف الازمه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ومن دوناتسكي ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
كيف تبدو الامور في الشرق الاوكراني
المعارك الضاريه في
الحديث ايضا كذلك عن قرب سقوط هذه المدينه
موديل منذ يعني يومين ونحن نتحدث عن تطبيق
ربما بشكل كامل من قبل قوات فاجنر شبهه
الرسميه لهذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه كيف
تبدو الامور
امامك على الارض
مساء الخير نايف بالفعل يعني المعارك
مستعره والقصف متبادل ما بين طرفين
الاوكراني والروسي هنا في مقاطعه دانياس
وخاصه في المحور الشمالي
تصريحات مستمره من قبل السلطات المحليه
هنا وكذلك من قبل مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر يعني
اخر تصريحات مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر قال بان
امدادات عسكريه وصلت للجيش الاوكراني في
مدينه باقمت والحديث عن عشرات الالاف هكذا
قال وان السيطره على مدينه باخمت لن تكون
بتلك السهوله واضاف بان الدماء تسيل
وتزداد سيلان كل يوم في تلك المدينه لكن
المعلومات من المصدر هناك على ارض المعارك
بان القوات الروسيه او قوات فاجنر تحديدا
ما زالت تتقدم من المحور الشمالي نايف
وصلت الى مدينه تدعى بلده عفوا تدعى
خروموف كما انها ما زالت تقاتل في على
اطراف ستوبنه هذه بلده ايضا التي اول
احياء التي دخلتها من المحور الشمالي لان
قوات فاجنر بالفعل في الايام الاخيره دخلت
الى عمق المدينه من الناحيه ايضا الشرقيه
تقدمت بعد المصانع والمعامل ووصلت الى نهر
يدعى نهر باخ موتك كما انها من الناحيه
الجنوبيه ما زالت تتمركز في المساكن
والمجمعات السكنيه التي تدعى بسباشكا اذا
ما زالت القوات الروسيه بشكل عام لان هناك
ايضا قوات خاصه عدا عن باقينا التابعه
للسلطات المحليه السلطات دانياس وكذلك
يعني فرق او كتائب من الجيش الروسي في
محاور مختلفه من مدينه باكموت ما زالت
تحاول الو صول الى بلده بغداد
نفك من الناحيه الشماليه والغربيه اذا
فعلا اكملت الطوق حتى الان لم تصل وتحاول
الوصول الى بلده بغداد
ليتسع الطوق وتضيق اعدادات وتضيق الطريق
على الجيش الاوكراني
بالفعل صحه نايف بالفعل يعني الجيش
الروسي يحاول الوصول
يحاول الوصول الى عمق المدينه والحديث عن
كيلو مترات بسيطه تفصيله عن عمق المدينه
لكن المعارك ليست سهله اليوم شهدت مدينه
يعني
تحليق مستمر منذ الصباح الباكر للمقاتلات
الروسيه واظهرت الفيديوهات التي يعني
يتناولها المواطنين هنا في وسائل الطوال
التواصل الاجتماعي عمليات قصف كبيره في
مدينه باخموت فعلا ربما ان هذه المدينه
استراتيجيه باهمتها للطرفين اذا كانت
للطرف الاوكراني فالاهميه تكمن في الصمود
واذا كان للجانب الروسي فهي تكمن باول
سيطره على احدى المدن الكبيره في المقاطعه
او في المحور الشمالي من المقاطعه اشكرك
جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل من دانيت مراسل العربيه رائد
الاخضر
الرابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
صحيفه كويتيه تكشف عن صدور مرسوم من عشره
ضوابط لتنظيم التركيبه السكانيه في البلاد
حياكم الله من جديد اصدر الملك سلمان امرا
ملكيا بان يكون اليوم الحادي عشر من شهر
مارس من كل عام يوما خاصا للعلم وذلك
انطلاقا من قيمه العلم الممتد عبر تاريخ
الدوله السعوديه منذ تاسيسها عام
1727 اضافه لكونه مظهرا من مظاهر الدوله
والدليلا على سيادتها ورمزا للتلاحم بين
افرادها
العالم السعودي يعود لتاسيس الدوله
السعوديه الاولى عام
1727 اخضر اللون ويحمل شهادتين في الحادي
عشر من مارس عام
1937 اقر الملك عبد العزيز العالم السعودي
بشكله الحالي العلم السعودي يمتاز برفعه
لشهادتين ذات القيمه المحوريه للسعوديه
يشير السيف الى اظهار القوه والعدل يرمز
اللون الاخضر الى السلام والنماء في الاول
من مارس عام 23 صدر امر ملكي بتحديد يوم
الحادي عشر من مارس من كل عام ليكون يوما
خاصا بالعالم الوطني
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو البحث
المتخصص في التاريخ السعودي الدكتور سعد
العريفي دكتور سعد حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه كثير من دول العالم تحتفل بهذا
اليوم يوم العلم لكن اسال اليوم للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه ما هي القيمه لان يعطى
يوم للعلم السعودي بلا شك اخوي نايف يوم
العلم هو يوم مهم جدا خصوصا اذا اخذنا في
الاعتبار انه رمز لوحده المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ورمزا لوحدتها ورمز لاصالتها
وانه يمتد عبر 300 سنه من يوم بدينا يوم
قيام الدوله السعوديه الاولى لذا يوم
العلم مهم جدا ان نفخر فيه هنا ونعبر عن
فرحنا بهذا اليوم المجيد اللي مدى اختيار
يوم الحادي عشر من مارس يكون هو اليوم
الرسمي ليوم العالم السعودي 11 مارس 1937
موافق 27 ذي الحجه 1355 للهجره يوافق
موافقه الملك عبد العزيز على
ما رفعه له مجلس الشورى من حيث
اقامه علم رسمي للدوله او شكل العالم
السعودي وبالفعل شكرا لعالم السعودي
باستنادا الى تاريخه وجذوره التاريخيه
هناك التطور في في العالم السعودي في
الدول الثلاث ويمكنها التطور اكثر تشكل من
يعني من بعد طبعا يوم التاسيس ومراحل
الدوله السعوديه الاولى والثانيه والثالثه
نريد ان نعرف اكثر عن تطور هذا العالم
السعودي في شكله في مضمونه في هذا الاطار
دكتور طبعا العلم السعودي
يعني اولته الدوله السعوديه منذ قيامها
الدوله السعوديه الاولى عنايه خاصه خصوصا
ان العلم هو هو الرايه التي تجمع
ابناء الوطن منذ العهود الاسلاميه حتى
قيام الدوله السعوديه الاولى لذلك حينما
قامت الدوله السعوديه الاولى اعتنى ائمه
الدوله السعوديه ومنهم الامام محمد بن
سعود برايه الدوله السعوديه وجعلها من من
الخز والابريسم اللي هي اجود انواع الحرير
وكانت قطعه مكتوب عليها لا اله الا الله
محمد رسول الله واستمرت من دون السيف نعم
من دون السيف في دوله السعوديه الاولى بن
عبد الله وابناؤه اخذوا نفس الشكل في
الدوله السعوديه الثانيه في احد الملك عبد
العزيز اضاف اليها السيف متقاطعان في اعلى
رائد التوحيد السيفان وتحتها شعار التوحيد
لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله في عهد
الملك سعود تغير شكل العلم الى الى لا اله
الا الله محمد رسول الله وسيف في اعلى ثم
سيف في اسفله وتحته نصر من الله وفتحا
قريب وفي
العام
1393 للهجره تغير شكل العلم حتى اصبحنا في
شكل العلم الحالي اللي هو لا اله الا الله
محمد رسول الله وبالالوان هي المعروفه وسر
رموز يا دكتور اللي موجوده في هذا العالم
السعودي لليوم اللي يمكن ان نتوقف عنه
ايضا طبعا هو الاخضر اللي هي رقعه القماش
وهي ترمز لها انما والخضره وكذلك الحيويه
والطبيعه التي تتمتع بها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وشعار لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله بلا
شك
دلاله على انها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تتخذ من هذا الشعار رمزا ودستورا ومبادئ
لاقامتها هذه المملكه المباركه والسيف يدل
على القوه والعدل وهذا ما نراه يعني عدلا
مع الجميع وقوه على المعتدين اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على حضورك معنا هنا في نشره الرابعه
الباحث المتخصص في التاريخ السعودي
الدكتور سعد العريفي شكرا دكتور شكرا لكم
كشفت صحيفه الراي الكويتيه عن صدور مرسوم
بتكليف مجلس الوزراء باعداد اللائحه
التنفيذيه لتنظيم التركيبه السكانيه والتي
تضمنت عشره ضوابط ابرزها تحديد السياسات
المتعلقه بالسقف المناسب لجنسيات العماله
وتفعيل اوجه الرقابه على التوظيف الوهمي
للعماله الكويتيه بالاضافه ايضا الى تحديد
السياسات العامه لتفعيل التكنولوجيا في
المرافق العامه بما يضمن تقليص العماله
وربط مخرجات التعليم بخطه التنميه الشامله
المرسوم الكويتي مشاهدينا كلف مجلس
الوزراء ايضا بتشكيل لجنه وطنيه مكونه من
تسع جهات حكوميه لتنظيم التركيبات
السكانيه
من الكويت تنضم الينا المحاميه عبر
الرفاعي حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض يا مرحبا يا مسهله
مساء الخير حياك الله مساء النور نسال
اولا ما هو الخلل بالتركيبه السكانيه في
الكويت التي ستعالجها هذه الضوابط وهذه
اللائحه الجديده ايضا
طبعا بدايه احنا لما نتكلم عن موضوع تعديل
التركيب السكانيه نحن نتحدث عن قانون صدر
في عام 2020 تحديدا تم نشره في نوفمبر
2020 رغم
تحدث عن موضوع تعديل التركيب السكانيه بعد
ازمه كورونا مواه ما وجدناه من تكدس اعداد
كبيره من الوافدين وعدم مقدره الدوله في
التغطيه لامور كثيره منها الصحيه منها
العلاجيه من الاسكانيه والغذاء ويمكن
سمعنا في الاخبار وعن طريق قناه العربيه
ايضا ان هناك بعض المناطق السكنيه التي تم
اغلاقها كليا بسبب عدد الوافرين وانتشار
المرض انذاك
فكان من الضروري جدا ان يكون هناك يتحدث
عن تعديل التركيب السكانيه صدر في عام
2020 في جار نوفمبر الى اليوم لم نرى
اللائحه التي نصت في الماده خمسه من ذات
القانون لتعديل التركيب السكانيه لم تكن
هناك يعني طيب دكتوره هذه ضوابط الجديده
والشروط العشره ايضا اللي اللي تابعنا
تقريبا دخلت حيزه تنفيذي اليوم حسب بعض
الصحف الكويتيه هل ستلبي كل الاهداف لضبط
وتنظيم هذه التركيبه السكانيه في الكويت
احد التقارير تشير بان نسبه العماله
الوافده في الكويت مقارنه بالسكان 70%
او الوافدين
نسبه المواطنين فما معادله يعني عادله في
موضوع التركيبه السكانيه وايضا القانون
لما صدى في 2020 وضع عده امور على اللائحه
عند اصدارها ان تراعي عده امور وهي سبع
سبع امور تراعيها وفي نفس الماده 4 من ذات
القانون في سنه 2020 من اهمها تحديد
سياسات حظر تحويل العماله الوافده بين
قطاعات الدوله وايضا تحديد الفئات
المستثناه ومتى استيعاب وقدره وزاره الصحه
والمراكز الوقائيه العلاجيه من الامراض
والام بي ال او المنظومه الصحيه كامله
لاستقبال العدد الكبير من الوافدين
المتواجدين في دوله الكويت مخرجات التعليم
ايضا كان من المهمات ان تنظر الى مخرجات
التعليم والسياسه بوضع خطه سياسيه عادله
تكون فيها استقطاب استقطاب الوافدين
ومكوثهم احنا يمكن شفنا كثير من الامور من
سنه 2020 وحتى تاريخ اليوم الكثير من
القرارات اللي اصدرت من وزاره الداخليه
ايضا قرارات وزاره من زارتها الصحه لتقليل
من عدد العماله الواحده التاريخ اليوم
احد الاعداد الضوابط اللي موجوده في هذه
اللائحه هي احلال الكوادر الوطنيه
الكويتيه بدلا من العماله الوافده وهذا
سؤال مهم
قوسين التكويت التكويت
مطالبين من زمان يعني
احنا نعرف في في كثير من الوظائف يعني
وظائف لا يشغلها العماله الوافده
كيف راح تتعامل الحكومه مع هذه المساله
طبعا احنا لما نتكلم عن التكويت في
الوظائف احنا نتكلم عن الوظائف الخاصه في
وزارات الدوله في مؤسسات الدوله لا تحتاج
فيها الى وجود القطاع الحكومي وليس الاهلي
نتكلم عن القطاع الحكومي احنا عندنا عدد
كبير من الوظائف المتواجده في القطاع
الحكومي عدد يعني اكثر من 200 الف موظف
وافد موجود في وزارات الدوله نستطيع
استبدالهم بالمواطنين الكويتيين بالتكويت
باستخدام الكثير من حمله الشهادات في اخذ
هذه الاماكن ايضا اذا احنا بنتكلم عن
القطاع الخاص اين القطاع الخاص
يعني المجال الكبير بعد انشاء هيكله القوى
العامله ودعم العماله اعطالنا مجال كبير
في تكويت الوظائف اللي كانت بالاخص او
ننظرها ان وظائف فقط
للوافدين وهذه تم اصلاحها من قبل الكثير
من الشباب الكويتي اللي احنا نشوف ه حاليا
موجود مكان العام في تكويه هذه الوظائف هل
هناك خطوات ملموسه مثلا منذ 20 20 حتى هذه
اللحظه بدايه المناقشه في هذه اللائحه
وهذا التنظيم لتغيير التركيبه
كان
الاعلان عن القانون 2020 اللائحه حتى
اليوم لم تصدر بصوره رسميه باعلانها
بالجريده الرسميه انما يتم مناقشتها
باداره الفتوى والتشريع حتى يتم اعتمادها
واعلانها بالجريده الرسميه تكون لائحه يتم
تنفيذها وتعتبر قانون يجب الاخذ بها
فمازلنا حتى الان الرؤيه غير واضحه لعدم
وجود لائحه يعني مهمه لكن هناك وعود كثيره
ويمكن متابعه الاخبار الكثير من الوزراء
اقاموا باحلال الوافدين ووضع التكويت في
الوظائف الحكوميه وكذلك القطاع الخاص ايضا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الكويت انضمت الينا
المحاميه عبر رفاعي الشكر جزيلا لك
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
شركه البحر الاحمر الدوليه تعلن عن احد
المنتجعات العالميه الفاخره في جزيره شورى
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت شركه البحر
الاحمر الدوليه عن اقامه مجموعه فور سيزون
لاولى منتجعتها الفاخره على شواطئ وجهه
البحر الاحمر بجزيره شورى الشركه اضافت
بان المشروع يضم 149 غرفه وجناحا ويهدف
لتقديم تجربه مميزه لزوار الجزيره
ينطلق في مدينه الخبر شرق السعوديه معرض
ارج وهي مبادره معماريه تقدم انشطه نوعيه
في مجال التصميم والعماره وذلك بهدف رفع
قيمه الجمال المعماري وربط المعماريين
بالمجتمع كما يجمع المعرض سنويا نخبه من
المصممين والمعماريين السعوديين لابراز
افضل اعمال الفن المعماري باسلوب مبسط
يسهم في ابراز الاعمال المعماريه
والتصاميم للمجتمع وقطاع الاعمال وصناع
القرار
يلقى مسرح الشارع رواجا واقبالا شرق
السعوديه حيث يمتاز بخروجه عن الطريقه
المعتاده للمسرح التقليدي هذا نوع
مشاهدينا من الفن بات يشكل اليوم انتشارا
ملحوظا في السعوديه بفضل قدرته على خلق
مناخ تفاعلي مع الجمهور وملامسه القضايا
الاجتماعيه المزيد مع الزميل على الاقب
[موسيقى]
بعيدا عن خشبه المسرح التقليدي يحتل مسرح
الشارع حيزا من الاهتمام لدى عشاق العروض
المسرحيه لقربه من الجمهور خاصه وانه يؤدى
في الاماكن المفتوحه كاحد اساليب العرض
المسرحي الذي بات يشكل حضورا لافتا في
السعوديه طبعا المسرح المفتوح هو نوع من
انواع المسرح المعروف المقدم يعني عالميا
في عده دول متنوعه ولكن نحن حديثنا صرنا
نشوفه في المسرح السعودي حاضر طبعا عنده
خصوصيه للمسرح الشارع لانه متاح تقديمه في
اماكن مفتوحه
بسلاسه ما في ارتباط بمكان للعرض ولا
بتركيز علشان الاضاءه والصوت
لكن معتمد تماما على اداء الممثلين على
فكره نوعيه العرض ومكان العرض والتفاعل
المباشر مع الجمهور
بساطه مسرح الشارعي وحواره المباشر مع
الجمهور استطاع خلق لغه من التقارب
والتفاعل ما بين الممث
لين للجمهور كما انه يستعرض قدره الممثلين
على الارتجال والبقاء وسط اجواء العرض دون
التاثر بالجمهور طبعا انا جربت كذا نوعين
المسرح اللي هو الشارع او خشبه المسرح
بالنسبه لي انا احب ان مسرح الشارع لالي
ممتع جدا لاني اكون في وسط الناس في وسط
الجمهور عاشر مشاعرهم اعرفها اتواصل معاهم
اكثر واكون بنفس المستوى معاهم فبالنسبه
لي انا مسرح الشارع حاجه جميله جدا المسرح
المفتوح يعطي
من يعني زوايا
كثيره بالنسبه للفنان والمشاهد يعني ويكون
قريب
الفنان من المشاهدين وكذلك المشاهد يكون
قريب يعني من
الجمهور من الممثل
اقترن مسرح الشارع بالمناسبات الادبيه
ومحاكاته للحياه اليوميه ومناقشه القضايا
والموضوعات المجتمعيه معتمدا في ذلك على
فكره العرض واتاء الممثل في امكانيه ايصال
الفكره وتفعيل مشاركه الجمهور في مساحه
قريبه خارج الستاري الاحمر من المنطقه
الشرقيه عن اللغبي العربيه
ونعود مره اخرى الى الخبر ومن هناك مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي يبدو ان عبد
الرحمن طيب عبد الرحمن رجعت الصوره مره
اخرى منور يا عبد الرحمن حياك الله معي في
نشاط الرابع من رياض الملفت يا عبد الرحمن
في المعرض اللي انت موجود فيه يبدو وكان
في عماره قيد الانشاء او اللي احنا نسميها
بالدارج العماره العظم فايش الفكره انه
يكون هذا المعرض ده صحيح
هو فعلا فكره خارج صندوق ان يقام المعرض
تحت مبنى تحت الانشاء لم يكتمل حتى الان
وهذا له علاقه بفكره المعرض وهي معرض يجمع
عدد كبير من المهندسين ومكاتب الهندسه
اكثر من 20 مكتب هندسي واستوديو وايضا
اكثر من 30 طالب
يقدمون اعمالهم الهندسيه ومشاريعهم امام
الجمهور وايضا امام الشركات العقاريه
والمقاولين ومهتمين في هذا المجال الحديث
اكثر ينضم اليها عبد الرحمن الشهري وهو
احد المنظمين هنا في هذا المعرض انا سانقل
سؤال زميلي نايف لك ليش اخترتوا هذا
الموقع وهذا المكان لاقامه المعرض هذه
السنه اكيد اكيد اول شيء بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم حياكم الله احنا سعيدين صراحه
بتواجد القناه مثل العربيه معانا في
المعرض وللامانه الاختيار كان بناء على
وجود المعرض من الاساس الفكره الاساسيه من
المعرض هو المنمليزم او التخفف والتصميم
بايادي
من مكتب اركمان فالمكتب هذا قرر انه يخلق
التجربه هذه المعرض يخلق تجربه متكامله
التجربه المتكامله هذه من بدايه المعرض من
دخولك انت راح تشوف المبنى قيد الانشاء
بتشوف ارتباط المعماريين والمصممين بهذا
المبنى طبعا احنا عندنا قصه معماريه نقدر
نقولها وروايه مع كل المعماريين
فيحبون المباني قبل بدايتها يحبون يشوفون
الكتل يشوفون الفراغات علاقه الفراغات
ببعضها فهذا الشيء الرئيسي اللي احنا نبغى
نخلقه من المعرض نبغى التجربه المتكامله
اللي توصل للناس باسهل طريقه ممكنه السنه
هذه نسخه الرابعه عبد الرحمن ما هو الجديد
في هذه النسخه ومختلف عن النسخ الثلاثه
الماضيه زي ما ذكرت ان التجربه هي اكبر
برهان على الاختلاف المواسم اللي قبل كنا
ناخذ اماكن بسيطه وصغيره ما تعكس كامل
المجهودات اللي في القطاع بشكل كبير الان
نشاهد احنا هذي نماذج لدورات موجوده الان
في الخبر هذه الدورات تصميمها بايادي
مهندسين سعوديين وتم تنفيذها باكثر من
شركه في هنا في الخبر صحيح هذه مبادره
مجسم وطن المبادره اللي غيرت من شكل الخبر
في منطقتنا واللي ساعدت على اثراء
المنظور الحضري في المدينه
كلم عبد الرحمن يعني ما هي الاهداف التي
تريدون تحقيقها في نسختكم الرابعه لهذه
السنه الاهداف للامانه كثيره جدا واهم هدف
هو ايجاد حلقه الوصل بين المعماريين
الممارسين والاكاديميين والطلاب فنحاول في
المنطقه هذه زي ما انت شايف المشاريع هذه
كامله هي مشاريع مختلفه من المشاريع
الكبيره جدا في المملكه ومن الطلاب
الموهوبين فاحنا نبغى نحاول انه نوجد
الحلقه هذه وحلقه الوصل بين الطالب
الاكاديمي الممارس في هذا المعرض طيب احنا
نشوف الاقبال كبير يعني الان تقريبا قبل
نص ساعه بديتوا والحضور متنوع يعني طلاب
ومهندسين مقاولين يعني تتوقعون اقبال كبير
خلال الايام الاربعه الجايه وقت المعرض
اكيد اكيد وانا ابشرك اتوقع ان هذا فقط
البدايه احنا لسه باقي ما افتتحنا
الافتتاح بعد عندنا تجربه الان هنا اتوقع
تجربه 3 دي الواقع الافتراضي يعني زي ما
في الاختلاف في شخص حاط الفي ار هذي وقاعد
يستمتع بالبيئه الفي ار تعطيها في على
المناطق الاخرى مثل المشاريع الكبيره
ريتال المشاريع المشاركه والمسابقات
المشاركه التجربه المتكامله في المعرض
يعطيك العافيه عبد الرحمن يعني نايف زي ما
حنا شفنا يعني معرض مختلف مميز هذه السنه
متوقع ان يكون اقبال كبير خلال ايام
القليله المقبله شكرا جزيلا لك يا عبد
الرحمن من الخبر مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي على هذه الجوله خلال هذه الايام
سيتقارب كوكب المشتري وكوكب الزهره ويمكن
مشاهدتهما بالعين المجرده التفاصيل في
تقويم عقد الزع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا جن الليل خلال هذه الايام فسنشاهد
المع الاجرام السماويه المسمى بالزهره
فلما جن عليه الليل راى كوكبا قال هذا ربي
فلما افلا قال لا احب الافلين وسنشاهد
ايضا اكبر افرادا المجموعه الشمسيه المسمى
بالمشتري فالمشتري والزهره هي زينه السماء
ان زينا سماء الدنيا بزينه الكواكب وخلال
هذه الايام سيتقارب كوكب المشتري مع
الزهره وهذا تقارب يسميها العرب بالاقتران
قران المشتري زحلا يرجى لايقاظ النواظر من
كراهه تقضى الناس جيلا بعد جيل وخلفت
النجوم كما تراها فالمشتري والزهره وسهيل
والمرزم نشاهدها بالعين المجرده طوال شهر
شعبان قال له شهر مارس يضاف اليها بدر في
منتصف الشهر القمري البدر يكمل في كل شهر
مره وهلال وجهك في كل يوم كامل من ذا الذي
اهداك اجمل صوره وحباك نورا في الفضاء
وجملك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ه بابرز عناوينها
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن اسقاط 10 مسيرات
اوكرانيه حاولت استهداف مواقع في شبه
جزيره القرم
الملك سلمان يصدر امرا بتحديد اليوم
الحادي عشر من شهر مارس من كل عام يوما
للعلم
صحيفه كويتيه تكشف عن صدور مرسوم من عشره
ضوابط لتنظيم التركيبه السكانيه في البلاد
انطلاق مرض ارج للعماره والتصميم في الخبر
شرق السعوديه بمشاركه مختصين وطلبه جامعات
شكرا لكم المتابعه نهايه الرابع عود
والقاكم يوم غد في رعايه الله